[Music]
[Applause]
okay so um I'll be talking today about
some recent exciting news especially on
the observational site where the
existence of the multiverse is concerned
Blanca's spoken planck was launched in
2009 and it was meant to improve upon
previous findings from w map which was
another satellite that was designed to
look for the Cosmic Microwave Background
now the Cosmic Microwave Background is
one of the strongest tools we have in
studying the very early universe because
it's a direct relic of the Big Bang and
it's everywhere around us today in the
sky of course at present the temperature
of the photons that make up the
microwave background in the sky is very
low because the universe has grown large
and therefore those photons have
redshifted but all of those all that
microwave background originates from the
time when the universe went through Big
Bang inflation and as is always the case
when quantum fluctuations are produced
immediately in in the metric of
space-time and also in that particle in
that primordial particle that we call
the inflation field as the universe
cools down of course many of those
primordial fluctuations especially the
short distance ones will collapse under
their own self gravitational forces and
create structure stars galaxies clusters
of galaxies eventually and ultimately us
that that's why we are here today
however the leftover remains as part of
the microwave background and and that is
the reason why so many experiments and
satellites have been developed into
studying that microwave background as
I'm sure you all are familiar with our
standard model of cosmology says that
the universe started with some party
all known as the inflation field that
was at very high energies and and that
the energy of that particle propelled
that initial small universe into an
accelerated expansion and and in other
words the universe went through a big
bang
phase and and it grew quite large quite
fast the the observational test of that
theory known as inflation one of the
observational tests is the microwave
background if that story is correct with
which it seems to be correct because
it's an exquisite agreement with all the
data we have so far in cosmology but if
that story is correct what we expect to
see in the sky today all those photons
lurking around and and all the structure
distributed in the universe since all of
those effects including structure
formation originated from that from
fluctuations of that initial in
flattened field then what we expect to
see today is a very homogeneous and and
uniform distribution of whether its
structure or the microwave background we
we expect all the features around the
sky tool to be spread homogeneously and
uniformly it doesn't matter whether I
look on this direction in the sky or in
another direction the sky should look
the same that that's one of the powerful
predictions of Big Bang cosmology of the
inflationary theory and and Planck of
course was the satellite was designed to
go after the microwave background and
check exactly for for that uniformity
and and homogeneity of the distribution
of the microwave background and and that
was the most interesting finding of all
what Planck found is that indeed at
short scales now I'm talking in terms of
cosmological scales so by short I mean a
hundred mega parsec or two hundred mega
parsec the size of galaxies so in in
those scales indeed Planck and W may
previously found an exquisite agreement
of what our standard model of cosmology
says and what they observed everything
is distributed uniformly and it's
homogeneous everywhere in the sky the
the temperature of the microwave
background
is pretty much the same everywhere the
the hot and the cold regions that that
plant was measuring they are also
distributed homogeneously everywhere now
let me make a caveat here whenever we
are looking at the over dense region in
the sky for example the star of galaxy
or on a collection of such objects
massive objects that will show up in a
temperature map that will show up as a
hotspot wherever you have a
concentration of mass that region is
solved if if there is emptiness like the
space between galaxies that will show up
as a cold area in the temperature map of
the sky and and that's what Planck was
was taking a snapshot of this hot and
cold spot the distribution of the hot
and cold spots what they discovered is
that at this short and intermediate
scales indeed everything looks uniformly
and homogeneously distributed as we
expect it and as it should be and and
that's a major success of our standard
model of cosmology what they discovered
with which makes their findings
incredibly interesting is that this
story changes drastically at the largest
possible scales if we are looking at
scales of say the size of the universe
known as the horizon scale or even
shorter scales but something a distance
comparable to the size of the universe
then the homogeneity and the uniformity
of the microwave background sky seems to
be broken and and that was one of the
most important findings of the century
it was a spectacular discovery it had
been previously of course seen by the W
map the previous satellite experiment
and even copy over two decades ago
however first of all our statistics and
technology were not good enough for us
to be able to tell that what we are
looking at is not an anomaly that comes
from nature but it's a statistical fluke
or a problem with instrumentation Planck
was quite advanced and sophisticated in
in terms of those problems that
technology problems and statistical
problems
they had a lot more data so they could
carry out better analysis and therefore
they confirmed whatever they found
nobody could question or doubt that that
effect that anomaly observed that the
largest scales might be due to something
else like a statistical fluke and and
that's why the the discoveries that
Clank made and and those scales are
extremely important and they relate
theoretically to a very complex but rich
new concept emerging in physics and I
should be very careful when I use the
word new because historians of science
know that the idea contemplating the
possibility that there might be more
than one universe and probably an
infinite number of other stuff out there
other universes or domains or whatnot
that possibility has been contemplated
for the last 2,000 years from simple
ideas to philosophical ideas to
scientific ideas however it was honor
that the existence the possible
existence of a multiverse was one of
those questions that was considered to
be in bad taste in in physics until
quite recently many of you probably have
heard of Hugh Everett and and what he
went through as a pioneer for suggesting
that the existence of multiple universes
is a real physical possibility he he was
writing his thesis that with John
Wheeler in Princeton and he was studying
quantum mechanics so he discovered that
if you follow quantum mechanics
word-by-word
then it leads you to the conclusion that
you do not end up with one universe if
you solve for a wave function of the
universe we are quantum mechanically you
don't end up with just one but you end
up with an infinite amount of universes
so ever it was the first one to have the
courage and say well there there is no
criteria no physical criteria why I out
of that whole array of mathematical
solutions I should say I like only that
one and throw away the rest so he
provided an equal footing in terms of
existence of mathematical solutions
being mapped
physical realities and and of course he
paid the price for that very few people
heard about this for 50 years and quite
recently the multiverse field as ESRI
emerged as this very interesting field
and and quite likely the the future of
theoretical and observational physics
the reason for this emergence of the
multiverse 50 years after Everett is
related to technological advances and
and the experiments like Planck for
example we may argue about our
theoretical tastes but we can never
argue about data data is data so
whatever an experiment finds we have to
take that possibility seriously and that
has happened in science more than once
dark energy is another example of that
happening however besides the the
experimental findings of for example w
map findings that something is very
strange with our universe at the largest
scales something else might be at play
there so besides those experimental
findings there has been also a
revolution in inter attica physics part
of it is related to recent discoveries
about nine years ago in string theory
now we don't have an underlying theory
of everything but swing theory is the
closest we can get at the moment perhaps
it's right or perhaps it's wrong
[Music]